foreign
[Music]
I can't run this club forever
I built this for nothing
this is our family
[Music]
you and me kid
from the beginning yes please
it was a golden age bike riders and I
never felt so I had a place in all my
life
that's when I saw him for the first time
it took my breath away
[Music]
later I married him
I thought I could change him you know
not to be different but to be
I don't know like he's Wild
hey
I told you to take that jacket off
what about the bar
Ney down
the club got real big real fast they
started running drugs gambling
prostitution is that what this club is
now
need to quit riding don't I say
yeah
if he wants to ride a bike you ride a
bike
[Music]
just think it over you know
thank you
[Music]